hey everybody welcome back to another
episode of visual effects artist react
we have a very special episode here it's
actually just me with two guests this
time I'm joined by David goyer and Chris
McLean David is the showing around
foundation has also written a bunch of
movies you've probably heard of worked
on The Dark Knight trilogy Man of Steel
the Blade movies but Foundation is
definitely one of the big feathers in my
cap it's something that I always thought
about working on and Chris has done
visual effects on a whole bunch of
incredible projects plus it's the visual
effects supervisor on Foundation it's
been four years in the making and you
know we're still going on it and it's
been a wild ride and I'm very happy to
be on the show I love Foundation we've
actually talked about it in two other
episodes these guys saw the episode and
thought it was cool enough that it's
worth giving us a call to come out in
the couch we're fans we're fans of
quarter crew fans of the show oh they're
so nice sweet well let's jump into it
[Music]
wow
the Empire is good for anything they
condemn well build so I want to
congratulate you guys on making the
first space elevator that I've seen that
seems to be an accurate space elevator
like it's tall enough
we cheated a little yeah there is a bit
of cheating but we also had it too close
in the beginning too because some of the
concept art that Rory did had it like
you know here's the counterweight here's
the planet and we want to see them both
in the same shot and then we we had to
redesign some of the shots we were we
actually were working on an idea that
had a space elevator in it a long time
ago as well you know what I think
they're talking about like okay what if
the ending of the piece is like the
space elevator it's like destroyed and
falls down and wraps around wraps around
the planet you know there's like a
canyon when it does yeah yeah yeah
and like seeing that happen in the show
I was like oh they did it
and like it looks so cool
I love that shot that's so cool it was
really hard to demonstrate the fact that
there were all these different layers on
Treader and that was one of the ones I
remember when we were working with the
team of like I just kept talking about
like what's a frame that we can use to
illustrate it like smashing through the
sky you know and that finally we sort of
cracked it but I think that part of our
philosophy with the show in general is
you know a couple times a season do just
a couple of really big ass sequences and
just go for it and just do them right
Chris's fingerprints are all over the
show in ways that extend beyond visual
effects Chris is also very close with
Rory our production designer Rory and I
we kind of get together and go okay how
much of this can you build how much this
can give us for real how much of this
are we going to actually have to do and
then we try to make it so that we don't
have like 100 set extensions to eat up
the budget and then we can spend the
money on the big shots otherwise it's
you know you would run out of money in
the first two episodes It's
pick your moments really you know and
obviously this was a big moment and if
you do a big moment like this it's sort
of the shot that fires off the season
then you don't have to do another Big
Moment Like This for a little while
wow that's a really cool space elevator
I mean it's supposed to go up and down
and fluctuate from space to Earth but
you know what's not supposed to be
constantly going up and down your mental
health that's why I'm here to talk about
our sponsor today better help better
help is the world's largest therapy
service and it's 100 online to quote
Patty from the UFC there's a stigma
going on in this world where men are
afraid to talk you know and I think
that's a thing it's an ego thing you
know you got to get past that thing but
it's okay to talk about your mental
health if you're going through things
it's okay to lean on support whether
that's friends or family that's fine to
you but if you don't have that support
system around you better help is a great
tool and a great option that you might
want to consider checking out betterhelp
has over 30 000 licensed and
professional experienced therapists who
are there to help you with a wide range
of issues you just take a quick
questionnaire kind of explain kind of
what your needs or what you're kind of
looking to get out of therapy and
they'll help you match with the perfect
person for you if for any reason you're
not gentling with your therapist or it's
just not the right fit you can switch it
anytime at no charge my favorite part
about better hope is that the
convenience factor I can shoot a text or
an email or even schedule a live session
with my therapist at any time kind of
whatever works for me so if I'm even
just have a thought and I'm like oh why
did that happen or why did I think that
way I'm going to shoot him a text and
kind of with my issue or my question and
he'll get back to me in a timely manner
man just start talking women too it's a
good tool I use it personally a few
other people at court or use it
personally so if you want to check it
out go to betterhealth.com quarter crew
or hit that link in the description
below and you can get 10 off your first
month but in the meantime let's get back
to the couch because Nico's about to get
clarification on that canoe shot that we
were looking at before when we looked at
Foundation
[Music]
no offense to the guys that did it but
we ran out of time I hate that the pipes
come out you know where see we were out
of money here and originally this is
supposed to be three shots who who was
the vendor on this I mean who did a
great job no no spin they did a great
job the problem is it was supposed to
happen in three shots and look I love
Marvel movies I've got three boys we see
all the Marvel movies right but I hate
when certain shots just completely defy
physics that thing does not obey the
laws of physics at all oh okay and this
one is just such a physics
and I'm I just uh it kills me it just
hurts myself this is part of that uh 90
10 that you don't like I heard you guys
talking about this and I was like what
the are they talking about how do
they like this shot well this is this is
why we actually we wrote you guys we
were we were scouting for season three
when we saw this and we were like yeah
we're watching this hey yeah
magic trick shot so in our previous
episode we were talking about the canoe
shot we were guessing that's how it was
done yeah I guess is that like you guys
just dropped the canoe to like kind of
get that Splash and then like you did
the actual shot with canoe afterwards
and mixed the two plates together is
that at all what you did no we did
the uh so the canister she throws in is
that's real that's real then we do a CG
swap over to you know the expansion of
the canoe and then the water Sim is All
Digital like there's no there's no
splash from the uh there's no splash
from the actual couldn't really the only
real Splash is the first Splash from her
that canister yeah wow yeah and there's
still some turbulence going on even when
we're doing something kind of virtual
like this we try to add as many real
elements as possible the best visual
effects are ones that combine real
elements and fake elements yeah if you
look at how quickly we go back to it
which was the real canoe it's kind of a
sleight of hand because you're paying
attention to this the things start to
unfold there go the oars from nowhere
and then she looks and then when we cut
back to it it's there yeah you know it's
just a kind of sled of hand but because
there was a real canoe there right after
that shot you kind of suspend disbelief
a little bit more so you Bravo it wasn't
as elegant as you surmise
time you and I had a reckoning
yeah let's jump into season two let's
can we start with uh episode one with
the chopped head
this is a sweet fight scene there's a
lot of work that went into this yeah
fight choreography
storyboards Lee train for at least three
months physically training but also no
stunt doubles in this in this scene he
was completely committed to it did a
spectacular job
think you can preach my heart
that single eye on the sliced head
that's looking at him when he lands next
to it I just wish we had made the I
blink
I mean the intention was to do that and
again we just ran out of money I think
in the first draft her head was just cut
off and then we did some different
iterations or it was halfway the top
half was cut off and then Chris did some
concept Dart and we decided that the
diagonal cut was more disturbing and so
we went for the diagonal cut
foreign
there's rig removal in these shots
because there's a little uh you know
pipe across his chest that's pumping
blood out she was wearing a green sock
Lara Byrne that plays demersell was it
green socks it's a lot painted no black
black with uh tracking markers on it
just yeah little little drag markers to
have her segmented head and we wanted to
kind of start the season off with the
bang and let audientists know that we
can do scenes like this on this show
it's not just a heady Naval gazing
science fiction show speaking of navals
his is missing yeah
yeah yeah we painted it out in all these
because he's he's a clone he's a clone
for some reason decided that they get
fed through their necks instead of their
belly buttons but yeah it's been a whole
thing that we have to deal with now I do
a lot of asking questions on the couch
it's kind of my job when I'm hosting
this show but I'm curious if you are in
my spot what questions would you be
asking what am I missing here what would
you want to ask that I haven't asked so
leave a comment down below fill up my my
questions Inspirations box with uh with
some new ideas here so yeah let me know
what you guys would want to ask
foreign
we have to talk about this sequence yeah
we have to talk about this sequence so
this is on an island called lagomera
it's this incredible location this is a
natural pool where under normal
circumstances people actually swim it's
like a public pool it looks very like
oppressive yeah and there was this
insane super swell we were supposed to
shoot there for three days or something
like that and these waves came in and
just washed the set away oh really they
would have killed anyone in there and so
we had to rebuild it in a parking lot in
Prague yeah and make it work so take it
away Chris and explain this this was a
disaster yeah so all of the coverage on
Jared was in the parking lot her
coverage we did up higher when we were
in lagomera from the pool so when we're
looking back towards the pylons yeah
those are real just not near the water
yeah and then if you really look at the
sequence if you see we framed out the
top of the pool there and we had water
cannons so that's all practical and we
were really judicious about where you
actually see things and where you don't
see things but a lot of the wide shots
so that that's parking lot and and
plates from the real thing all combined
so we shot some Drone footage but some
of it's comp but a lot of it was Digi
doubles she's not actually walking there
the Harry's not in the pool it's just
well some of them are Digi is it all
digital that's all you have to find I
love this visual of you guys putting
Harry Selden into like a bathtub in a
parking lot all right imagine you're on
a planet oh yeah
and here was game man I mean but that
was not fun for sure yeah one thing that
still bothers me about that is that we
didn't wait down the pillars in the
water though yeah you can see the little
pylons
that's one of the giveaways there I know
and we were like should we freeze these
and and it was too late in the game and
we were like we had to let it go so
hopefully the acting takes care of that
and not many people notice until they
watch the show yeah not everybody
yeah but I mean there's a lot of stuff
that we do like that where you know
hopefully the content is is going to
help hide some of the uh you know the
filmmaking Follies that we run into with
this stuff but that's one of the most
fascinating things about making films is
these because it's all Illusions right
it's all it's all stage tricks like he's
not actually crying he's acting like
he's crying you know it's these stories
of like hey we had this problem we have
to solve it and we're gonna do it in a
way ideally you can't notice but still
right in front of you the audience
doesn't know what they don't know and
just off camera you know are you know it
was a hot day in Prague and we were
literally in a parking lot
you know just hanging out
you know nothing says space show like
spaceships and planets and and then
alien creatures and we had a Bishop's
club which is a predator on Terminus in
season one and I wanted to show the
progression of time and to show that
they had domesticated some of these
animals so I said we're not just going
to put four shots of Becky in every
episode we're gonna have like three
episodes where she's in a lot and you
get to know her and she's got
personality and then in other episodes
you won't see her at all or you just
hear her but the hardest part of this
was the shots where Izzy who plays
constant is riding Becky
whoa
you know like everything on the show we
don't have enough money to do like the
jungle book version of uh an animatronic
buck and all that stuff so we took a
horse rig that the guys had from I think
it was Game of Game of Thrones hydraulic
horse buck that when an actor's on it
kind of goes up and down and it mimics
the movement of a horse but because
Becky's like a cat we ended up yeah we
turned it sideways so rolls from side to
side
but I love I love the water interaction
here yeah the guy uh the Sun and Chris
that played Becky for us the whole
season big I think he was like 250
pounds or whatever but he was uh some
man we were like I don't know if this is
the right casting for for Becky but he
came in and he nailed it but yeah in
every shot where you see Becky we have a
stunt man with a foam head yeah stunt
man with the foam pad and a gray
suit and yes he's acting so that the
actors have something to react to so
there's a lot of trust from the actors
because they've seen what we've done so
far yeah I mean season one was a little
hairy everybody was like uh how what is
this going to look like what what what
are you guys doing Scotty and Dan apple
or like I hope you guys know what you're
doing and you know season one came out
now everybody's just like oh you guys
are the the guy's doing it all it's okay
yeah we know it would be nice yeah it is
yeah it's good to have that kind of
trust especially from the quote-unquote
talent yeah for sure season two was in
that regard a lot easier because they're
like okay just go with us go with us all
right all right all right we'll go with
you do you guys feel like you still need
to prove yourselves
sure yeah yeah all the time I mean
every day
you know on set like I'll give myself a
grade but yeah we're very hard on
ourselves it was something Dennis
Berardi told me in visual effects you're
only as good as your worst shot so no
matter what you know we can have all
this amazing visual effects but then if
one shot is just garbage everybody
that's kind of how I feel about the
whole show
but the shots at the moments where we
fall down I'm like yeah I feel like we
failed yeah you said to me it's it's you
know what was it this is like acrylic
painting where it's not oil painting you
know we we let things dry a little bit
faster because we're moving a lot faster
watercolor you know it's more involved
in watercolor but it's it we don't have
the Kiara skiro of oil painting so it's
acrylic painting yeah is what we're
right that's a great analogy I mean
Foundation is my favorite Sci-Fi series
of recent history one of my favorite
Sci-Fi series of all time when
somebody's going to tell me a Sci-Fi
story I'm expecting the story to have
something in it that can only make that
story exist because some rule the
universe needed to be changed yeah
you're gonna tell me a story that you
could tell me in a normal place in a
classify what's the point right right it
can only be told in sci-fi so we've got
time dilation clone clones and AI
entities and things like that and
smaller black holes exactly and you guys
obviously you have your human elements
of the story which could exist across
any story but then you have actual
scenes with actual problems that only
exist because you built a world that
these problems can only exist well some
crazy ass happens in season two
I would ask like hey where can we see
more of your work I feel like it's
pretty obvious for this episode you can
check out Foundation season 2 playing
right now on Apple TV also after every
single episode David uploads behind the
scenes to his website which is super
cool so go check that out well thank you
so much for joining us guys really
appreciate it's been a pleasure yeah
it's been a pleasure so every once in a
while we get amazing guests on the couch
as you can see uh who knows who the next
one will be I'll have to subscribe to
find out